summertime in Iraq and scorching
temperatures are coupled with frequent
power cuts the Eastern Suburbans of
Baghdad are among the hardest hit
the state grid only supplies electricity
for three hours out of every six
seventy-year-old kadamia lives with her
family in their small house most of
their household equipment doesn't work
anymore
we don't use the fridge anymore because
it was ruined by electricity cuts and
our food perished these days we splash
water on ourselves with water to
alleviate the Heat
generators are the only option for some
Iraqis
War damage and Decades of neglected
infrastructure have long caused
shortages
blackouts have increased because some
facilities have been attacked by armored
groups some Iraqis have both generators
to hire them out to neighbors with a
fragile National Grid local generators
like these have become a profitable
business venture you can see their wires
dangling in streets and criss-crossing
alleys all over the country
posing a safety threat to residents
Iraq relies on gas from Iran to fuel
power stations which Supply the National
Grid
they normally produce around 20 000
megawatts of electricity
but need 24
000 megawatts during the peak summer
months to fill the Gap Iraq is getting
interconnected with other countries
the great connection with Jordan starts
with 150 megawatts and will reach 950
megawatts this is a double circuit
connection to also link Iraq with Egypt
Via Jordan in the future it's meant to
boost our grid in the western region and
later link Iraq with grids in the Gulf
countries and turkey
Iraq also needs to pay its bills for
Iranian gas Iraqi power stations need
around 35 million cubic meters of
Iranian gas every day but our 20 million
short because the Iranians have
suspended deliveries pending payment
which is the last thing Iraqi
electricity consumers want to hear as
they search in the baking summer heat
for alternative energy sources
foreign